why would you say it's not politically
correct i'm curious because it because
you're exposing that this really is an
industry I think that's kind of what
I've run across over the last seven
years is that the more people I talk to
says you're gonna have a hard time
trying to sell this one because it's
it's it's like you know two people make
a living doing what they do whether it's
attorneys you know mediators counselors
we need all of those things and parties
court fees I mean you know those things
add up and that's money that's revenue
and I don't know for me I think if we
did it the other way and we built this
country like it used to be where we're
teaching more how to build relationships
and talk to people we would probably
have we wouldn't be in debt and we
wouldn't have a lot of other problems
that's just my opinion right and maybe
you'll save some lives maybe you know
maybe distribution isn't the answer but
saving a life will be yeah I'm not
looking at the distribution anymore you
know I'm very fortunate that I had a
great week I had a great kick off this
week we had three theaters and you know
some people came up and said hey this
was a good movie it's good work and that
to me was good and someone that I talked
to yesterday said man I've been in this
thing for like five years you know this
is my help me you know that's that's
huge and so you're right if it saves
lives that's what we that's where the
turning point came in and it's not just
the parents is for the kids you know for
our children
you